bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on est au mwc
avec hervé sur le stand de huy qu alors
oui co je suppose que vous connaissez on
en a déjà parlé wiko c'est l'un des deux
constructeurs français de smartphones
qui n'est pas utile tout à fait et qui a
des produits d'entrée de gamme voire un
peu plus et ils sont vraiment très
gentils
[Musique]
m
or cette année vous avez lancé plusieurs
produits au mwc est ce que tu peux nous
dire quels sont ces produits quels sont
leurs particularités et puis après on
retrouvera dans le détail est pas super
eh ben on a vraiment présenté toute une
gamme de produits avec la meilleure
expérience utilisateur possible et donc
toute notre gamme de produits a minima
des écrans 18 9e
c'est un format d'écran qui permet
d'avoir la meilleure immersion possible
pour regarder des vidéos pour jouer à
des jeux vidéo des 79 euros donc ça pour
nous c'est super important c'est
vraiment laden de huy causé s'est
démocratisé la technologie pour la
rendre accessible au plus grand nombre
quels sont les nouveaux produits que
vous allez lancer cette année annoncé au
mwc
on a trois nouveaux produits qu'on
appelle chez nous dans l'entrée de gamme
avec des modèles qui seront de 79,99
euros
ok donc c'est la gamme jerry notamment
de l'audience inquiets le fameux dix
neuvième à 79 euros
on a le génie et le tome i iii qui sont
de smartphones ultra performant alors
ensuite après ces produits qu est ce que
vous avez comme a promis que tout
nouveau alors nous allons présenter le
viol ait le vieux go et le vieux max qui
sont trois nouveaux modèles dans ce
qu'on appelle chez nous la gamme moyenne
gamme avec des produits qui vont aller
effectivement c'est qu'on n'est plus
dans des 159
179 1190 très fort au hockey avec des
produits toujours format de suite la
lièvre donc ça c'est vraiment notre
volonté c'est d'avoir la meilleure
immersion c'est le minimum qu'on doit
être aujourd'hui sur toute la gamme rico
a minima sur des écrans 18 le diable et
on va avoir des fonctionnalités comme la
reconnaissance faciale et après tu me
disais vieux deux vieux de vue de frau
qui sont des produits que je trouve moi
tellement sublime en termes de design
[Musique]
donc est ce que tu peux nous présenter
ce nouveau view de pros de huy qu alors
le vieux de pro et avait été de bijoux
parce que c'est un écran 19/9 qui permet
une immersion totale dans l'image
sa pêche le nombre le format encore plus
grands comme ça c'est un format encore
plus grand et là on a en fait une
surface d'écran qui est quasiment on a
plus de 80 portion en fait de la surface
du téléphone qui est dédié à l'écran qui
est dédié à l'écrou j'ai vraiment c'est
un écran vraiment très immersif pour
regarder des vidéos pour jouer des jeux
vidéo c'est vraiment c'est coiffé et
surtout c'est un véritable bijou de
technologie parce que on a une double
caméra située à l'arrière une caméra 5
mégapixels et une caméra 8 mégapixels
qui permet en fait de faire des photos
en moi de panoramas typiquement l'âge et
d'appâter la caméra 5 mégapixels en
appuyant juste sur ce bouton je vais
avoir un angle à s'entendre avec un
poêle à mettre effectivement de pouvoir
gord hill et les charia performant sur
le printemps alors qu'un petit henri
richard yacht show c'est parce que j'ai
choisi a forcément un effet six chalets
sur des grands angles armée à 120 degrés
on t'aime de résolution passe à 8
mégapixels mais en revanche quatre super
appréciable c'est que il faut pas
rentrer dans un menu compliqué ou quoi
que ce soit on est juste appuyer sur un
bouton et on va effectivement leur sens
de l'urgence absolue je mettrai en
appuyant ici on va pouvoir voir des
effets ce qu'on appelle le blu ray fait
qd on va avoir des flous artistiques là
je suis sur la canette de coca qui est
juste en face et ici j'ai un flou
artistique est derrière et avec la
canette qui traiterait annette et ça
c'est vraiment voilà c'est la lave la
volonté de nikos à chaque fois de rendre
l'expérience utilisateur la plus
agréable possible et surtout la plus
simple possible et à des prix les plus
accessible possible
aujourd'hui tous les écrans tout et
téléphone
santé sont minimes avec informative qui
viennent des 79 euros et on l'a sur le
vu de plus de pros deux modèles très
haut de gamme handicap
pourquoi il faut à 199 et 299 donc là on
à 299 euros avec un écran 6 pouces
absolument 6 pouces et 19 deviennent
19/9 c'est un écran lcd
c'est un écran absolument ce maquereau
en cdi ps c'est un écran hd plus on a
une super résolution et en termes de
qualité d'image c'est vraiment très
présent en fait le hd plus c'est le
format hd mais sur les écrans 19/9
adapté aux 39 tout à fait ok super alors
les caméras je me disais c'est du sel
c'est du 16 mars à 16 mégapixels pour la
caméra principale à l'arrière jacent 16
mégapixels pour la caméra frontale
auquel ce cas très important et pour
nous en tout cas on est convaincu que
c'est fondamental c'est que on a
développé des partenariats avec des
entreprises comme qualcomm comme d'exo
comme vie dense et survit danse on a
développé des services vidéo qui nous
permet d'avoir une stabilisation d'image
deux fois supérieur
un des smartphones on va lire
traditionnelle et donc avec la caméra
frontale et on a le stabilisateur vidéo
mouvance moment gourous personnes qui se
pressent dans cette fille en train de
skier avec le stabilisateur vidéo
evidence
on a une image que deux fois plus stable
c'est quand même super passé 5
stabilisation optique ou numérique
c'est une stabilisation numérique donc
céder ses actifs logiciels chez les
morceaux de sa carrière soit mais c'est
c'est vraiment super performant
[Musique]
c'est vrai qu'en termes de prise en main
il est bien moi ce que je trouve
vraiment bien sous le sceau typologie de
produits cas pendant qu'un diktat de le
voir ici de parole caméra en eau
toujours de bois qui va traîner dessus
je sais que c'est une tannée et au delà
de ça on a la reconnaissance faciale
c'est la corde
typiquement avec nos smartphones je vais
prendre mon smartphone il va me
connaître je vais pas avoir à taper le
code va faire de chez mac os x arrange
toi tu vas prendre études tu devras
effectivement contrat et ça on a ça sur
les modèles plus de jus de pro d'accord
mais on a également sa sur des modèles
un peu plus moyenne gamme notamment sur
le vieux max et sur le bio go comme on a
déjà cette reconnaissance sociale et
donc c'est en gros tu as tu as un peu la
publicité re not a tout d'une grande
mais pour le prix d'une petite c'est
super alors qu'au côté performances on
installe dragonne mon asthme est de
règle on a un processeur sur le vieux de
pro qui règne entre 450 et sur le vieux
de on a un stade
quelque 135 ok mais qui est extrêmement
performant par rapport à effectivement
aux produits c'est amplement suffisant
pour les gens du streaming vidéo et tout
est optimisé de toute façon j'imagine
absolument et c'est également alors
c'est à dire un point super important
c'est que nos volontés ça chaque fois
d'optimiser l'expérience utilisateur et
notamment sur des smartphones d'entrée
de gamme
l'appel des gars moi et chez nous que
soit le tome i iii le jerry de lenny on
va avoir en fait là l'édition pour les
eaux qui l'édition go back lankais cette
validation qui est d'analyser au
contraire c'est une version qui est
optimisé par rapport pour processeur ou
des par rapport à la capacité du produit
et donc on va avoir une expérience
utilisateur hyper fluidique la rapide
même sur des smartphones qui ont
2 - 1 gigaoctet de mémoire et des
processeurs un peu moins puissant
l'april croissance un peu comme qu'on
peut retrouver sur le bus de pau est
sûre le biais de voir alors solution l'a
confirmé trois cas d'erreur on est à
quatre arrêts du gardien sur le but de
pros et on est à 3 sur le but de ce haut
lieu de 64 joueurs de stockage
absolument immonde peut en plus bien
évidemment l'optimiser avec une
librairie et sur le vieux deux ans des
actes rentrant de gérer le stockage est
assez fragile g merlus ont arraché les
gouttes alors et en super en plus soudé
regarder la prise jack
je trouve ça une aberration de jerry
biret foncé dans les smartphones cité un
peu citer un peu de file system la
musique il faut impérativement
effectivement le prix jacques on a
franchement un produit est ultra
performant avec un design qui est
vraiment optimisé un contour métal sur
le fût de pro
on a vraiment un produit qui est qui est
magnifique et le revêtement s'adapte ça
va te faire sourire mais c'est
véritablement de la nanotechnologie
parce que c'est un revêtement qui est en
plastique mais sur lequel on a intégré
des nanotechnologies pour andorre
vêtements très résistant cette nature
opaque honneur qui est incassable
d'accord est ce qu'on est vraiment ce n'
est très résistant tu peux pas le payer
ici surtout très très jolie en termes de
glasnost et méthode absolue middleton
est un peu c'est clairement
effectivement un aspect métallique
c'est un ses remix entre l'aspect métal
et l'aspect vert et ça ça me donne
vraiment ce design très très jeune c'est
plus premium est effectivement avoir un
côté plastique
c'est classique l'inconvénient série
trash de loi oui et je sens que tu
protèges avec un une protection et l'or
c'est une très bonne question parce que
en fait qu à des protections sur le
produit qui vont te permettre d'accéder
à tous très rapidement à tout et appelle
toutes les notifications en navarre
éthiquement dédier toute une gamme de
nouvelles protections voix sur ce
produit qui vont rendre le produit plus
résistant et d'encore plus encore plus
pratique
bon ok quotas peu techno cette cellule
au micro usb pour le recharger tout
assez haut parleur mono stéréo de vivre
ici tu as deux haut parleurs
ok donc c'est
val et festive ok c'est un produit qui
sera disponible entre deux camps alors
le vieux 2 sera disponible dès le mois
d'avril à 199 euros et revu de pro sera
disponible dès le mois de mai à 285 x
qui s'adressent ces produits louis
causse et qui aujourd'hui le coeur de
cible chirico c'est un peu compliqué de
d'abord lé le client type mais si vous
ciblez réellement d'abord on sait tous
les consommateurs
j'imagine mais maintenant il faut être
clair sur des modèles un peu entrée de
gamme c'est souvent quand même des coups
mais un peu des primo accédants cd des
personnes qui achètent des smartphones
pour la première fois et c'est pas
forcément qu'ils vont acheter les
smartphones c'est souvent le papa ou la
maman qui va acheter le smartphone
procédé utilise bien de 12 à 18 ans donc
ça c'est vraiment nos modèles de la
gamme y donc il commis des délits
l'égérie c'est vraiment les primo
accédants
après qu'on va aller sur les modèles
view on devra avoir un consommateur un
peu plus exigeants qui va avoir des
fonctionnalités de caméras en photo et
vidéo un peu plus pointus dont classe
avec le modèle anges ont veillé en
moyenne gamme et sur les view 2 et vue
de pro là on va avoir vraiment des
consommateurs très très exigeant mais ce
qui est quand même intéressant c'est que
des 199 euros là ce format d'écran 19
viennent tu as une caméra qui est
véritablement optimisé aussi bien sûr
caméra arrière que sur la caméra avant
et on a avec le vul de pro un produit à
299 ou en gros
un peu la pub de renault c'est à tout
d'une grande mais pour le prix d'une
petite c'est vraiment ça d'une manière
générale on peut dire que le marché des
smartphones d'entrée de gamme et moyenne
gamme est en train de vraiment se
démocratise et parce qu'on voit qu'il ya
un fossé entre vraiment des produits
qu'on va trouver aux alentours de 100
200 euros et des produits à plus de 1000
euros est ce qu'on parle pas de la même
chose ce n'est pas le même monde et
c'est vraiment deux clans qui se
démocratise et qui prend de plus en plus
de place aujourd'hui alors c'est ça
prend de la place et sur le marché est
effectivement moins de 100 euros
- 250 honda les produits qui sont de
plus en plus performants et aujourd'hui
enfin aujourd'hui quasiment plus
personne n'achète de future flotte parce
que quand tu vois pièce nous par exemple
chez ricoh ont fait d'être un fan des 49
euros pourquoi aller pourquoi les
acheter un feature phones à 29,39 euros
quand tu peux avoir un smartphone à 44
donc on a une demande vraiment
importantes sur des smartphones d'entrée
de gamme avec des fonctionnalités qui
sont calmes de plus en plus poussés
parce que comme un à 10,79 euros
on a déjà l'écran 18 9e donc voilà on
essaie vraiment de rendre encore une
fois c'est la dernière innovation
technologique le plus accessible
possible
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo dit
pas ce que vous en pensez est ce que
vous êtes déjà client chirico est ce que
vous pourriez devenir
comment est ce que vous trouvez ces
modèles comme d'habitude je vous invite
bien évidemment à mes cd jolie pousse à
vous abonner parce qu'on va parler
toujours plus de produits tech innovant
que ce soit des smartphones même de la
robotique de plein de choses donc c'est
super intéressant
on reste connectés merci beaucoup verger
merci on va dire longue vie à vos
produits sont très sympas tout cas merci
merci a bientot soyez sages et puis il
ya bientôt tchad
[Musique]